if you're someone who has a moral
dilemma against AI or you hate it please
don't become your parents and what I
mean by that is it's just fascinating to
watch so many of my friends who's made
fun of their parents for not getting a
smartphone or pushed their parents 25
years ago to get on email and like would
make fun of their parents and they don't
realize they'd become their parents
their nay saying a blockchain and AI
like technology will always move if you
put your head in the sand nothing good
happens of it so before you have some
profound opinion because one of your
friends said something why don't you go
spend 10 hours actually tasting it and
understanding it and that would be the
biggest take I have for this group about
AI